Deadpool 3 looks to be delayed and the
reason it isn't on the calendar of
upcoming releases is likely to affect
lots of other Hollywood projects over
the next few years here's what's
happening Deadpool fans are a bit
alarmed after noticing that the upcoming
third installments of the mark of the
mouse movie series is conspicuously
missing from Disney's release schedule
comicbook.com was one of the first
Outlets to notice that Disney's calendar
of upcoming releases doesn't appear to
include Deadpool 3 which was originally
scheduled for release in May 2024 the
purported calendar includes releases
through June 14 2024 including the
sequel to Pixar's hit inside out but no
Deadpool the highly anticipated sequel
is bringing back Hugh Jackman to play a
version of Wolverine hey Hugh you want
to play Wolverine one more time
yeah sure
it also includes Jennifer Garner's
Elektra reportedly and marks Deadpool's
first official entry into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so it's pretty
understandable that its Omission from
the official calendar is causing some
fans to stress onset photos taken while
the movie was still in production showed
a potential Throwdown between Jackman's
Wolverine and Ryan Reynolds massive
vigilante based on the success of the
two previous Deadpool films and the
return of two beloved characters to boot
it's pretty thrilling for fans to
anticipate it will also apparently have
to wait a while it isn't a huge shock as
to why both the writer's Guild of
America or wga and sag-aftra the Screen
Actors Union are still on strike halting
most major Hollywood Productions that
includes Deadpool 3. in July 2023
shortly after sagafra joined the wga on
the picket lines to demand a new deal
from the studios variety reported that
Deadpool 3 was halting production
Deadpool 3 was the first major Studio to
shut down production due to the strikes
and since then other highly anticipated
projects including in Gladiator 2 and
wicked have also stopped production
while writers and actors strike notably
e-news reports that Deadpool star Ryan
Reynolds and wife Blake Lively donated
one million dollars to the sag-aftra
foundation which is giving emergency
assistance to actors on strike in early
August the writer's Guild of America
began its strike on May 1st 2023 and a
mid-julaida Screen Actors Guild
officially joined them the result is an
historic double strike against the
alliance of motion picture and
television producers or amptp one of the
issues that handles the use of AI
technology in both writers rooms and on
screen the amdtp at one point reportedly
suggested they should be allowed to scan
background actors likenesses and use
them in perpetuity while only paying
said actors for a single day of work
writers and actors are also fighting for
fair residual pay in a streaming age
writers and actors from popular shows
such as Abba Elementary and Orange is
the New Black and even stars like Mandy
Moore from This Is Us have revealed
their shockingly small residual checks
from streaming Sean Gunn and brother of
director James Gunn noted that despite
appearing in more than 100 episodes of
Gilmore Girls Netflix has provided him
with very little for the show being a
staple on the service all I know is that
I get a little tiny cut of the licensing
fee they pay to Warner Brothers
television and film have been changed
permanently since the Advent of
streaming services and the artists
behind the work we love deserve to be
compensated and protected while they do
so so that's then the strikes definitely
don't seem to be losing any steam
despite repeated attempts at
negotiations between the amptp and the
guilds no deals have been reached
putting the fate of movies like Deadpool
3 in flux for now
[Music]
no